Wall Street Journal
Savers pile money into bank CDs as rates
top five percent did you see that where
banks are uh topping five percent and by
the way when is the last time we had
five percent I think the last yes well I
can tell you who it was I remember who
ran a commercial every day talking about
five percent four point five percent
five point five percent you know what
the company was ING Direct I don't know
if you remember that Americans are
rediscovering CDs as a safe haven amid
High inflation Rising interest rates and
economic anxiety balances in CDs soaring
from 36.5 billion dollars in April
is this correct
damn
did you see these numbers balances
increased in CDs from 36.5 billion
dollars in April of last year to 418
billion Dollars January of this year no
time that's 12x no just 400 yeah 418
billion dollars banks are competing for
deposits again uh after several years of
showing little inclination to do so the
top Builder nationally available
12-month cities are now between five and
five and a quarter which is
significantly higher than the average
yield on a 12-month CD currently at 1.59
CDs work best for relatively short-term
savings goals such as down payment or on
a house it's crucial to shop around and
consider but Pat that's the problem is
that you're pulling money out of
deposits and you're putting them in CDs
yes and now you have long-dated
maturities that there's a mismatch yep
that's a good point what do you think
about it Tom I I well first of all I
agree about with the mismatch but the
second part is I think there's a there's
your there's your answer mortgage
originations are at their lowest point
in 28 years
um and where's the down payment money I
think you're seeing a lot of this is
look this is liquid money Americans have
that a significant amount of that you
just described is basically down payment
money that's on the sideline this is and
I read last Friday the most rate
sensitive General the 35 year old home
buyer today is the most sensitive that
generation
um most re-sensitive buyer in the
history
because their lives they've never seen
this they don't understand that it was
perfectly reasonable to have a six
hundred thousand dollar home with a six
percent loan on it with reasonable
property tax District they don't
understand that that's perfectly
realistic they've been living in a
payment economy from their car to
everything else they've had that has
been so artificial because of zurp and
so now it's all coming home to roost and
they're like six percent good Lord and
their grandparents are saying why are
you screaming I want to show a scary
number I want to show you a scary number
I want to show you a scary number
somebody just sent this here to me
saying Pat take a look at this here uh
uh and this is by Nick Nick James who's
if you're watching this this is you send
it to me so zoom in here FDIC a goal all
the way to the bottom what their balance
sheet is and how much they're protecting
right now the amount of money they have
if you look at that closely they have
125 billion dollars you know how much
you're protecting
9.9 trillion dollars
did you did you hear that yeah say that
one more time okay yeah
a lot of numbers on this page right has
a 125 billion dollars in their balance
but they're insured deposits the quarter
million dollars on the millions of
accounts that are out there they're
protecting
9.926 trillion dollars
what this is showing is the fact that
you can't just say we got you don't
worry about it no you don't have the
money
you don't have the money by the way you
may be able to do it for One svb Bank
maybe for a second bank if all of a
sudden you get a third fourth fifth
seventh eight nine tenth they they can't
do anything at that point if this
happens so you're saying they weren't
just concerned about the poor citizens
with deposits at svb that they looked at
their own dashboard and said good Lord
we better make sure there's no runs on
banks Monday that's right Tom that's
exactly right but by the way you know
what that number is do you know what
that number is like what percentage of
the insured deposits they have what is
is it 1.26 it's 1.26 percent
yeah that's that sounds about right let
me do you understand what I'm asking
here yes what they have they only have
1.26 yeah 900 would be 10 so yeah it's
about one and a quarter percent yeah oh
that's it the reserve ratio okay so that
should answer the question here on
whether they're saying well I just asked
the question right now on Twitter I said
keep it at 250 500 1 million Unlimited
uh uh 36 is the highest said keep it at
250. 500 000 is the lowest 12 percent
one million is the second lowest 23 but
do you know 29 said keep it unlimited
you know what that tells you most people
have no clue that the number and the
kind of funds that we have how the hell
are we going to be able to protect this
unlimited when you only have 1.26
percent of the dollar a month insured
right now the FDIC
can I tell you actually why low key I
kind of really appreciate what's
happening right now with the Silicon
Valley Bank because it's it's you know
this whole return to normalcy and all
that
these are the types of conversations
that we need to be having As Americans
with the debt that we're taking on in
America right and the situations that
are going on in the banks over the last
few years the the whether it's cultural
issues like the wokism stuff and lgbtq
and critical race Theory and all these
then it became abortion and covid and
Jabs and oh nfts in Meadow world and I'm
buying real estate in the [__]
metaverse who gives a [__] this is what
makes America tick these are the types
of issues that we really need to focus
on great point and get on the same page
here not all the nonsensical stuff like
I just bought an nft in the metaverse
with a coveted mask attached to it like
that's like let's get past that and get
back to reality here I think that's very
important absolutely I just ask you to
be a little sensible for people that are
going through challenging times and your
body have a little sympathy and
compassion for the folks that bought
land at 4.8 million dollars
versus absolutely have a little bit of
respect you know what
a lot of people right now so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign